dylan bundy is on the bump this is his
11th start
3.12 era oh good breaking ball one down
the ferris looking on the strikeout two
outs in the top of the first here is
isaiah connor philippa
this one hit well out to left field back
on it to the wall upton looks up it's
gone
and kinder falloffa with his third home
run of the year
and again the rangers come out of the
gates swinging this afternoon it's one
nothing
and right off the bat kinder fellow gets
the rangers started
for the rangers kyle gibson he's had ten
starts he's two and five
trout three for 12 in the series two
strike pitch to trout
and that is strike three called big
strikeout of mike trout and they're two
gone
a two gone and here's anthony rendon
there's a swing of the miss he strikes
out rindon our one nothing starts this
afternoon for the rangers nick solac
coming up
off-balance throw solid gets out of line
pretty well he looks safe from
up here they're going to challenge it
that'll get overturned so solac is on
board with a lead off infield base hit
texan again on solac does have
five steals this year in six tries so
you may be thinking about it
he is going breaking ball misses inside
and the throw to second nowhere close so
solac
with his sixth stolen base of the year
and nick gets himself into scoring
position for tajita
who's batting 250. oh he's
he's gonna grow into that body throw
some heat there's a bouncer down the
first baseline
and that's a fair ball solac comes in to
score
and tahedah goes to second base then the
rangers lead two to nothing
walk hit by pitch and walk to load them
up is dassey hitting 243
crown ball to short to hate him to odor
double play shohei scores angels get on
the board no rbi for stassi
2-1 texas runners at first and third now
for nick
solac this one looped out over second
that could be trouble and it
drops down in front of trout base hit
solac
gets tavares to the plate and it's three
to one didn't do a ton with it but
just enough to plate the run the door at
the plate now two two
odor goes down swinging at the breaking
ball the inning is
over bundy gets the strikeout his
second one texas here the fourth has the
bottom third of its order up it to
hayden
dietrich and mathis
lifted on the right side shallow right
center field
fletcher going out taylor ward calls him
off
i don't think trout saw that real well
off the bat as well good job by
ward as he's saying he can see that
thank you for that one 16 change-ups
thrown
today by bunny to seven for strikes
in the air almost the same exact spot
that the hater hit his
trout's there two down that one was not
hit
as high so ward nowhere near the picture
no but he was still
working his way there full count lifted
toward right center field how about this
same spot
all three that's incredible the angels
have them loaded single walk and walk to
start off this inning and another
golden opportunity for the angels the
batter will be taylor ward
the 1-2 and there's a bouncer third base
kind of for leftover to the plate for
one
and they'll take that one they get the
force out at home
for the first out of the inning and
they'll happily take that out
bases are still loaded but one away
dashiell bad bases load of one out now
ohtani the base runner third base of
stasi lines one out toward left field
that's going to fall in for a base hit
ohtani will score
upton's being waved home to throw to the
plate is not in time but two rbis single
and we're tied up at three that was
great base running by justin upton
joey otani because you're a third base
you have to wait a little bit but upton
read that when he saw that baseball
being down
credit upton for that third run and a
base hit
by max stassi first and second one out
new ball game tied at three through the
left side of the base in being waved
around
on this one is ward and the throw to the
plate is cut off and the angels have
themselves a 4-3 lead angelton simmons
with his 10th rbi
bases loaded again this time for jared
walsh 3-1 drilled out to straight away
center field tavares going back that one
is gone
grant salami time for jared walsh halos
have opened it up here in the fourth
those numbers power numbers rbi totals
in the month of september and that
baseball went a
long way grand slam first of his career
that ball was
absolutely crushed 8-3
halo is leading two outs here and
derrick dietrich coming up
with the angels leading eight to three
swung on and lying down the right field
line if it's fair it's gone it's hooking
it is
history a two-run homer for derrick
dietrich
lefty the lefty right down the line and
right and the angels lead has been cut
to eight
five trout's had a no for three dates
trump puts this one out the left field
zolac coming on he'll dive he can't get
it gets by him
it'll trickle all the way to the warning
track trout's on his way to third
and he will easily get to third on that
triple that's his second of the year
i don't want for three had a single in
the fourth inning
brendon goes down looking he doesn't
like that call
and he waves them off he just gets
ejected that's the first
rejection for anthony rendon as an angel
as soon as you wave off an up part like
that more times than not
because i'm sure there was something set
as well it's automatic first of all you
can't argue balls and strikes automatic
ejection
two down jeff mathis so for three down
goes mathis light that baby up as the
angels pick up the victory this
afternoon eight five the final they also
pick up the series taking three of four
from texas to wrap up their last home
stand last home game of the year